ben shapiro editor-in-chief of The Daily
wire syndicated columnist host of the
ben shapiro show banner you shocked we
got to this point
not at all I mean I think that this has
been going on for at least a couple of
years here it started on college
campuses obviously we've seemed at
rallies during the during the last
election cycle remember there was a
rally for President Trump in Chicago
that was shut down due to tactics like
this I don't find any of this
particularly shocking I guess I'm just
shocked by how much of the mainstream
Left has decided to endorse it I mean
there been Democratic leaders who have
said that these sort of tactics are
unacceptable but I'm not sure they're
not being outflanked by the radical base
at this point has this ever happened to
you what happened to all of these
individuals or Pam Bondi my gosh they
got up in her face I know that you've
you've there been protesters when you
speak at schools but has anything like
that happen when you're out at a
restaurant or a movie theater No thank
God does one of the benefits of keeping
kosher when I go to kosher restaurants
and generally pretty popular so what
about this you know there are a number
of major newspapers today the the New
York Daily News the LA Times they're
talking about how this could backfire LA
Times writes resist too far Pelosi tries
to tamp down progressives public shaming
of Trump officials and she's not the
only one Chuck Schumer essentially came
out and said hey stop yeah the problem
though is that you have people like
Simone Sanders on CNN yesterday saying
that it is a is a part of white
privilege to call for civility and she's
not the only one saying that he said
John Legend yesterday do the same thing
on Twitter where he suggested that
calling people out in public places
destroying their ability to have dinner
standing outside their home and this is
all stuff that should happen if you
disagree with the policy enough and this
is why I say I think that you know Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer may be
representing something good on this
particular issue but their base is not
particularly interested in what they
have to say or at least a large segments
the base say bad you know my worry is my
worry is the natural response is to do
the same thing back to the other side
and then Republican activists are going
to be disturbing other people and other
restaurants and at movie theaters and at
the park and then the family so more
than likely involved because that's what
they do they find out where you live I
don't want Republicans to mimic this I
mean isolate these incidents and stop
them I think there's got to be a huge
national awareness not a response
I totally agree with that and I think
this is one of the big problems that we
have in our politics right now is
everybody assumes that they're being
victimized and therefore their reaction
is okay so I wouldn't be surprised if
some folks on the right see this as
permission to go do this to folks on the
left I think that a lot of folks on the
left see this whole tactic as a response
to President Trump being ruder rallies
and such and the problem is once you see
yourself as a victim I mean
psychological studies are pretty clear
on this once you see yourself as a
victim you're far more more likely to
see yourself as someone who's capable of
victimizing others it's okay to
victimize others because you're just
responding well once you feel like
you're responding it makes it gives you
a lot more moral credence to go out and
do something bad to somebody else I
think that's what the left is feeling
today you talked a little a little bit
about Hollywood the Hollywood director
and the producer Judd Apatow he tweeted
this out he's talking about the
president he says he's a Nazi he wants
no judicial process he kidnapped
children and commits acts of violence
for political gain and to support his
racist views he admires violent
dictators Trump is a Nazi the debate is
over soon we will have proof he is a
Nazi supported by the Russians your
reaction
I mean delusional nonsense read a damn
book but unfortunately in in Los Angeles
this is sort of become the way people
think because it's a water-cooler town
and everybody thinks the same way you
can say crazy things like Trump is a
Nazi and get away with it if Trump were
Nazi does Judd Apatow really think that
he'd be able to go on Twitter and say
stuff like this the Nazis were not
famous for their tolerance of dissent
particularly in this sort of manner